thanks T for the introduction so this
talk is about the dichotomy theorems for
exact counting graph homomorphisms so in
the talk I will cover some of the
dichotomy theorems for counting crab
homomorphisms and then I will try to
show you some segments of the proofs
some for the yagos mcpot and some for
the hardest part was the go to
demonstrate some of the commonly used
techniques in this area now these
results are not very recent I think the
most the nearest one is already five
years ago still remember the summer I
spent at Madison with Jeanne and yeah
but that was already five years ago so i
apologizing a divisive if some of the
parts of the talkative already seeing
them before hopefully this would refresh
your memory about these dichotomies
theorems so I probably heard about the
world dichotomy a lot from GE stock
yesterday so dichotomy theorem of
complexity dichotomy would be a theorem
that classifies the complexity of
collection of problems not just one
single problem but hopefully a
collection as big as possible and
usually such a theorem building above so
called tractability criterion it's a
condition on the problem definition and
really the theorem says that if your
problem satisfy this condition then it's
easy to solve otherwise you can show
that it's it's hard so one of the
classical results in this direction is
schaeffer's dichotomy theorem it's for a
decision version of CSP over the boolean
domain okay i will not defined CSP i
think many of you are familiar with CSP
because it's not the focus of the talk
today I will define them more formally
and tomorrow
talk but there is this feather and
bodies conjecture that this dichotomy
should hold for CSP for any language
over any finite domain for any such
language the conjecture says that the
problem the decision problem is either
in p or NP complete and the past we have
right now is the dichotomy theorem for
the massage 3 but this talk is about
counting problems so here are some
classical counting problems like
counting vertex covers counting
colorings counting satisfying
assignments counting perfect matchings
now this one may not be familiar to some
of you it's you know given a graph and
you count the number of induced
subgraphs with an odd number of ages but
we'll see later like this problem
actually played a pivotal role in the
sequence of dichotomy theorems that
we'll see in a few slides so there are
three well study frameworks for
accounting problems or collections and
more and more general accounting
problems there are these counting graph
formalisms which we'll talk about today
counting construct constraint
satisfaction problems i'll talk about
them tomorrow and there were these
holland problems Ginny and ham well
talked about
so so let's start with the definition of
pro forma morphisms given two graphs
undirected graphs so for this talk
whenever a gruff comes up its own
directed so given to undirected graphs
homomorphism is from G to edge is just a
map from the vertex set up g to the
vertex set of etch with the property
that every age of g is mapped to an age
of edge and the comp reform home offices
were first studied by lowbies and i
think this is one of the theorems he
proof about reform Amorph isms and
actually in the theorem the number of
homomorphisms played an important role
so the theorem says that take any two
graphs H and H prime they are isomorphic
if and only if you take any other graph
G and the number of her mama mama isn't
from g2 edge and from G to H prime are
exactly the same if the isomorphic then
these two numbers should always be the
same for any g but it's only a fan only
of thing
now the first work on our forum
amorphous and some you know dichotomies
for proforma morphisms is this dichotomy
theorem by hell and nature trail and the
decision version of the problem is also
called edge coloring so H is the rough
so you take any edge you know fix any
graph edge that's the graph view map to
and the problem is to decide given a
graph input graph G whether there exists
a homomorphism from G to edge every fix
the graph H would define you a problem
and that's the class of problems that
we're interested in here and how initial
trail prove that every such problem is
either in polynomial time or MP complete
now we're interested in the counting
version so let's just give the notation
which will see again and again in this
talk so given that fix the graph edge
i'm going to use eval edge to denote the
following problem the input is the graph
G H is fixed and we're interested in
creep in computing the number of
homomorphisms from G to edge so again
every fix the graph edge would give you
a problem and we have this dichotomy
theorem bike tire and Greinke which says
that for any edge this problem is either
solvable in polynomial time or shappy
complete and here is the track beauty
criterion basically the trackball cases
are graphs in which every connected
component is either an isolated vertex
or complete graph with all the self
loops or complete bipartite graphs these
are the only trackball cases and if your
graph does not fall into one of these
cases then it's it's in track bar it's
sharply complete
oh my gosh you take up if I'm gonna go
with self oops yes no that's that's easy
that's Impe so solvable in polynomial
time if every connected component is you
know one of these three graphs three
types of graphs so bye-bye complete
graph with self loops I just mean if you
look at the adjacency matrix it's all
one that corresponds to attract bookcase
and you can take the disjoint union of
such graphs that's do structure that's
still sellable in polynomial so we can
then see that vertex covers and
colorings d colorings can be both
expressed as a vow edge you know
counting graph for morrisons for some
small graph edge for example for vertex
covers actually just a graph with two
vertices and these two ages one aged
between them and one self loop so it's
clearly a graph that violates the
tractability criterion so we know by the
dichotomy theorem that this is shappy
complete and the same for D coloring
because the the graph is should be you
know the complete graph with no self
loops and by the dichotomy theorem it's
also shappy complete now for this
problem i mentioned earlier counting sub
graphs with an odd number of ages it's
not clear how you can express this
problem using as a vow edge for some
graph fix the graph edge but it turns
out that you can express it by
generalizing discounting problem to
graph or mobile physics with weights so
more generally given any symmetric
matrix a we use eval a to denote the
following problem so is a symmetric
matrix and for now let's assume that a
entries of a can take the most general
complex values
so take any graph G and an assignment
see that assign values or indices of the
matrix a to vertices of V each such
assignment defines an age weight on each
h XE you and PCB and if you take the
product over all ages that's what we
call the weight of the assignment of
this assignment and the sum that we're
interested in is this some let's called
Z sub a of G over a sum of weights over
all possible assignments so if you
spelled it out it's this sum of products
here now the connection between this
problem and the counting graph
homomorphism problem is that when you
take a to be the adjacency matrix the 01
adjacency matrix of the graph edge then
these are essentially the same exactly
the same problem because this weight is
one if and only if all these ages of G
or map to edges of H and 0 otherwise so
these two problems are exactly the same
it is function Z sub a is also called
partition functions in statistical
physics and now actually call them
partition functions in the rest of the
top
now back to this example counting
induced subgraphs with an odd number of
ages it turns out that this this problem
is equivalent to computing the partition
function with this matrix a 1 1 1 minus
one is two by two very simple Hardiman
matrix and here is the connection if you
take any assignment of B and think about
the graph induced by vertices that are
assigned to the weight is minus 1 if and
only if this graph has an odd number of
edges because because only ages in the
sub graph get the weight minus 10 other
ages get wait one and it's the way this
one otherwise now using this observation
plus another observation that the total
number of assignments is exactly to do
that a number of vertices these two
problems are equivalent if I know how to
solve this one then I can easily count
sub graphs with an odd number of edges
and in general if you allow weights like
roots of unity then we would get
interesting matrices like this and we
want to know how difficult these
matrices are and just a heads up that it
turns out that all these matrices are
check go and we'll see how what's the
app isn't behind all these track pro
cases in in a few slides so here amiga
is third root of unity that as a fifth
root of unity and these two are the so
called Fourier matrix is three by three
and five by five four matrices which
I'll define in a few slides but the
point is that all these three matrices
together with this two-by-two matrices
there or cha are they all correspond to
attract were cases
so after the dichotomy of dire in green
here for counting graph for morrisons or
equivalently 401 matrices we have this
dichotomy theorem by bullet off and
growth in 2005 it's the same statement
but now for non- symmetric non-negative
matrices so one thing i would like to
point out that is here i'm using our sub
a 2 denotes the set of algebraic real
numbers just to make sure that so we are
fine with the representation umbers as
long as you take any reasonable
computational model for algebraic
numbers this theorem worked out but in
this talk don't worry about you know
algebraic numbers or their
representations just just take it as
real numbers
and this is the tractability criterium
of their theorem it's probably the most
natural generalization of the dichotomy
criterion of Diana and Greinke oh it
says that a gives us the polynomial time
case if and only if a is first of all a
block diagonal matrix and every block is
either a rank one matrix or has this
form so two by two matrix the diagonals
are zeros and the one to block is rank
one matrix so these are all the
trackball cases if your matrix does not
look like this then it's it's it's a
Sharpie hard and I said this kind of
generalized diron in green here because
for rank one matrix is like a complete
graph with self loops and this matrix
would just simply similar to complete
bipartite graphs now you can put brown
qua matrices there instead of you know
all one matrices but describe the
similarity i would deserve a site like
this theorem has really really a lot of
applications and it's it's just very
easy to apply it and actually all the
harness proofs i'll talk about today and
tomorrow reductions to this dichotomy
theorem the reason why it's so easy to
apply is is the following observation if
i have a non-negative matrix and i'm
interested in its complexity then all i
need to do is to look at its two by two
your sub matrices if i'm able to find
identify or two by two sub matrix of
this bigger matrix which has let's say
at least the three positive entries but
it's not rank one then i can just apply
this theorem and claim that it's shall
be hard this all you need is to if you
want to prove this may
this hard just try to identify two by
two matrix which has three positive
entries but not rank one and recently
there is the new exposition by grove and
30 lists a few shortcuts in the proof
for this disc I khatti Meethi now after
non-negative matrices it's just natural
to move on to real or complex weights
and once you move to you know real or
complex ways you've got cancellations
this master of cancellations show up now
cancellations sometimes lead to very
efficient algorithms such as you know
our wisdoms for determinants and polo
graphic evidence by valiant in 2004 so
in general cancellations would give you
more tractable cases which turns out to
be the case as we'll see in a few slides
this somehow makes the proof of a
dichotomy more difficult because you do
typically the boundary between the track
pro and intractable cases become more
complicated and it's just become more
difficult to figure out where exactly it
becomes tractable
but dichotomy theorems arise and we have
first in 2009 this dichotomy theorem by
Goldberg Grove German and thoroughly
which shows that for any non-negative
symmetric sorry Rio and symmetric matrix
the problem is either computable in
polynomial time or shall be hard and
then there was generalized by chingy
myself and pinion to all the complex
matrices symmetric and complex matrices
now I will not be able to state the
track bidita criteria for either of
these two papers because it's actually
much more involved than for example the
criteria of bullet off and growth I
think if I want to state it formally I
need at least like 10 slides for that
purpose but roughly speaking trakdot
matrices corresponds to certain rank 1
modifications tensor products of those
for your matrices you use saw before
I'll define in a few slides
and I like to just point out that this
these three words Rank 1 modifications
actually has a lot of work hidden behind
these three words
so here is the so we've covered all the
theorems and hero here is the plan for
the rest of the talk first of all I want
to show you the algorithmic ingredients
of these dichotomy theorems I will show
you you know what are the algorithm that
were used to solve those trackball cases
then i'll give you a segment of the
harness proof will prove will give a
self-contained proof and the hope is
that I can use this proof to demonstrate
to elementary but also commonly use the
techniques in all these works called
building graph gadgets to do reductions
and also interpolations so let's start
with the algorithms and just as a
warm-up let's look at the rank one
matrix and let's show that rank one
matrix is the petition for function is
to be easy so easy to compute so a is
the rank one matrix which means there
exists a vector B such that you can
write AI J as bi times PJ this is the
partition function that we want to
compute now the first thing i did here
is just to replace the assignment by a
sequence of variables where x i denotes
the value assigned to vertex number I
and fear we plugging this expression
then the next observation is this
product you can actually write it as a
product over ice and each factor is B
sub X I to the power of the degree of
vertex I in the graph so this now
becomes a product of things over eyes
over the vertices and it's easy to
rewrite it as the product of sums but
now each of these sounds are very easy
to compute because remember the matrix a
is the fixed
constant so the size of the matrices you
know em is a fixed constant we can
afford to you know some bob m sings here
and then take the product a similar
algorithm would work also for you know
such two-by-two matrices with the rank
one matrix p
and the next thing is also easy if you
have two matrices that are both easy to
solve and you take the direct sum up to
these two matrices then you should also
give you a matrix that is easy to solve
so first of all it's without loss of
generality to assume that the graph
we're interested in is connected because
if you have a graph with multiple
connected components then the partition
function of this graph is just the
product of the partition function over
the product of the connected components
so if G is connected then it's easy to
show that all the assignments seeds that
have nonzero weights are basically those
map or the vertices to the first blog or
the assignments that map or the vertices
to the second block so we can write the
partition function as the sum of the
protection function over a using a 1 and
the potential function using a two so if
post a1 and a2 are easy to solve a is
also easy to solve
and but we've done so far as basically
we covered all the tractor cases in
bullet off and grove star coffee theorem
okay so with two slides will be proved
like half of the theorem even though i
would say the hardest part of that
theorem is like 100 times more difficult
than but at least state mumbai's this is
half of it now the next thing is what
about this matrix 1 1 1-1 i think it it
has been open for some time like we
don't know how whether this is easy or
hard but then there is this really nice
observation made in Gulberg broke at all
growth during and 30 that if you index
the rows and columns of this matrix x 0
1 or Z 2 then you actually have this
very nice expression the XYZ entry is
just the minus 1 to the power of x times
y the only chance you get a minus 1 is
both x and y are one and using this
observation we can plug it in the
partition function and we get this
expression where we have a sum over a
bunch of variables over z2 and each term
is a power of minus one so it's either 1
or minus 1 and in the exponent we have a
quadratic punim of x1 through xn and it
turns out that you know such sums are
easy to compute they can be computed in
polynomial time and i think this is no i
don't know which paper give this without
the first but I it's definitely in this
book by lido and leader later in about
finite fields so it's said that if you
take any quadratic polynomial and this
sum is computable in polynomial time in
polynomial time in end
the number of variables now combining
this theorem together with this
observation this connection we know that
the partition function of this matrix is
easy to solve and the same house for
this four by four kodama matrix which
takes a little bit work because you you
have to try and see that if you index
the rows and columns by zitu by zitu so
let's say index the rose by 00 01 10 11
then you can express the entries as
minus 1 to the power of x1 y2 + x2 y1
using the same argument would reduce us
to the how isn't behind this theory
and it turns out that this theorem can
be generalized to work for any Q any
integer Q not just for two not just for
prime numbers or prime powers it can be
extended to any integer Q so given Q and
quadratic polynomial over zq this sum
can be computed in polynomial time so
minus one is replaced by your cube root
of unity and the exponent is again a
quadratic polynomial over x1 through xn
and it can be computed in polynomial
time even if q is given as part of the
input so encoded in binary and even if
we are not given the prime factorization
of q now once we have this algorithm
immediately we know that other career
matrices are tractable so here is the
definition of the Fourier matrices and M
by M for matrices the entry satisfied
this expression the XYZ entry is just
the MS would have unity to the power of
x times 1 these are free matrices and by
the this theorem we know that all of
them correspond to track / cases
also we can take tensor products of any
of these matrices I'm not going to do
that but some calculation if you have a
tensor product then you can write the
partition function as the product of
partition function using the two
matrices separately so this roughly
speaking covered most of the trackball
cases in the real and complex graph for
morrisons or partition functions
remember I said earlier that most of the
track bookcases are tensor products of
Fourier matrices and now we know their
or attractable
so before moving on to the hardest part
I just want to show you this cute and
very short very very short proof for the
Q equals 2 case because you know the
idea generalizes to any Q but it was
more work so the proof basically just
has two cases in the first case we have
a quadratic term F X I square and the
other case you know every term is across
to M xixj i not equal to j so i think
this is the case when we only have
questions then we write the poem you in
terms of X 1 in this way then L is a
bilinear form and F prime is quadratic
polynomial then in the sum let's sum
over X 2 u 3 X M first and then x1 and
it turns out that this son of x1 only
depends on the value of L now it depends
on X 2 3 xn and it's too if n if l
equals 0 and 0 otherwise so this clearly
simplifies the exploit the sum to be
this one where we no longer have x1 but
has this condition that L should equal 0
but this can be down can be also removed
by a replacement a variable and this
would reduce the sum into a new some but
now with a minus 2 variables just keep
doing this each round either you already
know sorry each one you would get a new
factor of 2 here and after let's say n
minus 1 runs you can just do it brute
force the other case is exactly the same
except I think these two rows get
switched so the condition is that our
should be equals 1 but everything else
is the same so this finishes the proof
of the theorem that any such sum given
any quadratic polynomial it's easy to
compute
now for the for this general theorem I
want to point out that at the high level
it's similar each one we just find a way
to reduce the sum to a kind of smaller
sum but now there are two cases either
we can similarly reduce the number of
variables by at least one or we
sometimes need to reduce the size the
size of Q and the other thing is when
we're interested in the case when q is
given in binary not fixed but as part of
the input then Gauss Tom's play a really
important building block of the
algorithm the reason being that even if
x1 even if let's say I only have one
single variable x1 I cannot afford to
boot for some take the sum because it
has q many times and q you know as part
of the imports of here is exponentially
large but when that happens it actually
is closely related to Gao sounds you can
use Gauss on the expression behind Gauss
onto computed exactly and efficiently
so these are everything about algorithms
next I will show you a segment of the
harness proof and it's called the group
group condition lemma so here is the
definition let a be a symmetric M by M
matrix we say it's a discreet m discreet
unitary sorry capital m discreet unitary
if first of all every entry a IJ is ms
power of unity and also the first row is
all one and because it's metric the
first column is also or one and also you
take any two rows they are soaking them
meaning that their inner product is 0
and here is the definition of the inner
product this means the complex conjugate
if you have a matrix satisfies or these
conditions we say it's a discrete
unitary and here is the so-called group
condition llama it basically says that
if you have a matrix which we already
know it is discrete unit way for some
integer M then either this matrix should
satisfy the group condition which I'll
define next or you can order or you can
already show that the problem is Sharpie
hot if it violates the group condition
then you can already show that the
problem is a sharpie here is the group
condition it says that you can take
basically any two rows of the matrix
your I and J could be the same I take
the Haddam a product you know entry wise
multiplication of these two vectors you
get a new vector and the condition says
that this new vector should also be a
row vector in this matrix the reason why
it's good condition is that if you if
you satisfy this condition then the rose
under the hardware product would be a
group that's that's why it's called a
group condition
and the lemma basically tried to show
that every discrete unitary matrix is
either either satisfied the group
condition or we can already show it it's
happy home
before proving this here is the
motivation why we want such a lemma the
reservation is that these four matrices
they all said is they are not only
discrete unitary they are disagreed
unitary but they also satisfy the group
condition you take any two rows here do
the Hanuma product it would still give
you a row in this column sorrow in this
matrix and the next Lama says that
basically these are all the discrete
unitary matrices that satisfy the group
condition so every discrete unitary
matrix that certify the group condition
must be the tensor product of four rare
and so called generalized for your
matrices I don't think it's important
here but these are basically the
four-by-four hard ama matrices you saw
earlier those are called generalized for
your matrices but forget about this for
now it tells us that once you get a
matrix that is discrete unitary and
satisfy the group condition it's the
tensor product for your matrices and all
these matrices we have seen in the
algorithmic part that they're all
tractable so once you have a discrete
unitary matrix once you already know the
matrix is discrete unitary we get a
dichotomy theorem because either it
violates the group condition for which
this lemma tells us that it's shall be
hard or it satisfies postconditions
discrete unitary and group condition
then this lemma tells us it's actually
one of the matrices that we know how to
solve efficiently
and the group condition was first
introduced in the paper by Goldberg at
all four plus 1 minus 1 matrices and
then was generalized to all the complex
valued matrices or the roots of unity
stated earlier
so I have I think about 12 13 slides for
the proof of this lemma but here is the
high-level sketch so i have this matrix
day that is discrete unitary but will do
is to construct a signal sequence of
non-negative and symmetric matrices it's
called them beef bracket p for every
integer p positive integer p and we're
going to show that all these matrices
each of these matrices the problem of
computing the partition function can be
polynomial time reducible to the problem
defined by a then we move on to show
that one of these two cases happen
either one of these matrices to give us
a sharpie hard problem and this is done
by invoking the dichotomy theorem of
bullet often grow we just look at these
matrices closely and try to apply this
there dichotomy criterion and see if we
can show that one of them is violates
the criterium and it's sharpie hot if we
can do that this polynomial time
reduction would also tell us the that
the problem defined by a is shall be hot
on the other hand if we cannot show this
or every matrix B bracket p satisfies
the criteria of bullet off grill and
growth we're going to use this as a
really really strong property to show
that a satisfies the group condition
and the first part where we construct
these matrices and give these reductions
you can place where we use graph gadgets
and in the second part where we show
either this or this happens is the place
where we use interpretations
so this is the first gadget a graph
gadget is just is just the graph but now
with two special purchases called u and
v i highlight them in red here and then
you can add you know as many vertices
you want and as many ages as you want
here in this picture I use a blue sick
page to denote M minus 1 parallel ages
and just a remember that M is the
parameter in the unitary matrices
and here is the second gadget you start
with the first gadget but now make a
copy of C and D so now we call them c1
d1 + C to D 2 then just make a copy of
all these ages between c1 d1 and UAB re
and put them here so we always have one
copy of a and B but when P goes up we
have more and more pairs and the piece
gadget has c1 d1 C to D to up to you see
P and D P so this is how we construct
the the piece gadget for every integer
positive integer p
now how we use these gadgets are given
the graph say gee you can replace every
of its H by let's say the piece gadget
so here we first remove that age and
then identify the two special vertices
of the gadget with the two vertices of
this age so here I basically replace
their age by the first gadget and you do
this for every age you pick a pee and
you replace every age by the piece
gadget and we call the new graph we get
G bracket p and it turns out that there
is the symmetric matrix B bracket p or
derive its increase the on the next
slide but there is such a matrix which
have the same size of as a but satisfy
this expression if you take the
partition function of G using be bracket
p it's the same as the partition
function of the new graph g bracket peep
and now using it in such an equation
would give us automatically a polynomial
time reduction from matrix B bracket p
2a because whenever I have a graph G
that comes in and I want to compute this
I can just you know do this replacement
get a new graph G bracket be and you
know ask for the petition of G bracket p
under eight that go it's it's only this
way
now what is the entries of B bracket
beam if you're plugging you know all the
the definition of the partition function
and the construction of B bracket p the
IJ entry of B bracket p is the following
you assign value I to this special
vertex you assign J to this special
vertex V they are fixed they receive
values I and J respectively and then you
allow the rest of vertices to take all
possible values and you take the sum of
weights over all such assignments that
would give you the IJ entry of B bracket
p and the B bracket p we get in this way
would satisfy the equation and has the
polynomial time we do reduction to 2a so
for example this is for be bracket one
it's rj sentry everything just just by
definition but i only want to point out
that we have these conjugates here
because for example we have the
conjugate of a sub B D because between B
and D we have not just one age but
capital M minus 1 ages and because we
know that all these numbers are a mess
roots of unity taking the m minus 1
power is exactly the same as taking a
conjugate that's how we get there are
these four conjugates here they cause
positive for blue ages in the picture
now it's clear that every age is
incident to either C or D so we can
write it as the product of two Psalms
one over C and 1 over d and just stare
at them for for 45 seconds you will
figure out that these two are conjugate
of each other so it's exactly the norm
of this song but squared so what we have
here is close the expression for the IJ
entry of the first matrix where we have
a sum over all possible pairs of a and B
and then we have this sum and take its
norm and square it similarly we can we
can do matrix B bracket 2 and it turns
out that the only difference is that the
power the exponent here is now for
in-state up to that's the only
difference and in general for the peace
matrix everything is the same except
that the power is no to pee
and for convenience let's just rewrite
this sum as this inner product where we
first take the Haddam a product of the
ice Crow and the conjugate of the chase
row and then we take the product of the
ice row and the conjugate of the bistro
and then do the in the product after
that we take the norm and raise it to
the 3 p's power and we sum over all
possible values of a and B now it's it's
a fairly complicated expression but the
first observation is that it's it should
be clear that it's non negative let's
forget about palatable it should be
known actively because it's the sum of
norms it's positive because if you set a
to be a and B to BJ then these two are
exactly the same vector and we're taking
the inner product of the same vector so
we would get something positive we would
get em em to the 2p so every entry is
actually not only non-actor but positive
it's also symmetric now it's a it's not
straight forward from this expression
because in despression AI and AJ are not
the same like we have a conjugate I'm AJ
but it's not surprising because if you
go back and look at the gadget the
gadget is symmetric on you and be but
also I mean this i J is equal to G I
because you know we have this sum over
all possible a and B here so these are
symmetric and positive matrices it's
like the best place to apply the
dichotomy theorem a bullet often Grove
before that let's take a closer look at
the diagonal entries i equals J once I
you goes Jay the first vector just
becomes the 01 vector he just
disappeared and then this becomes the
inner product of a throw and the bistro
and this expression we know exactly what
it is because the matrix is supposed to
be unitary discrete unitary so every
inner product here is either 0 if a is
not equal to B or m if a equals B if you
go through all possible pairs of a and B
we have exactly m pairs where this no
this in a Productivity mm to the 2p plus
1 so we know exactly what the diagonal
entries are now we can apply the
dichotomy of blood Bullet often growth
so what we have here we have positive
matrix every entry is positive and we
know exactly its diagonal entries
they're all the same then the only
chance that this matrix survive you know
bullet often Grove is you know is that
the whole matrix has the same value
every entry is M to the 3p plus one if
the matrix doesn't look like this we
already know it's shall be hard and
because we have a reduction to a this
also tells us that a is shall be hard
and we're done this is the first case of
the theorem and we're done but the only
case it left is that actually these
matrices each of the matrix hassocks has
the same entries every entry z is equal
to M to the 2p plus 1 and in this case
we'll use this to show that a satisfies
the group condition
and this is a place where we use
interpretations so fix a pair ing i not
equal to j fix a pair and let's say
we're just you're interested in the b
bracket p the IJ century and it has this
expression now let's take let's ease
this following limitation so X sub IJ is
the set of all possible values of this
norm of this inner product by taking an
A and B to be all possible values and
for each possible value of being X sub
IJ s IJ bracket X tells us the number of
pairs a be such that this is equal to X
now once we have this temptation here
you can rewrite this sum as the sum over
X IJ and sij bracket x times X to the 2p
just plugging the notation here now of
course we have no idea what x IJ
contains what are the possible values
this can take but at least we know it
can it can be zero and it also can be
able to get them you can just plug in
set a equals a and B equals J and this
would equal to M to get zero we can plug
in x equals I think I and be something
different function then you would get
zoom so even though I don't know what
exactly they
13 X sub IJ I know 0 & M or two of its
end and it turns out this is enough for
us to figure out what exactly xij is
because let's take these equations or
pee from one to the size of xij minus
one these are all the equations we need
we don't need equations for larger p
plus this equation that if you sum over
SI j should be equal to M square because
we have exactly n square many pairs of a
B and these expressions together form a
penguin system it's a linear equation
system and coefficient matrix is of
animal matrix and it ship has a unique
solution but we know that it has this
solution the solution is set s IJ
bracket em to BM there are pairs that
give us m and m square minus m pairs
goodness 0 if you plug these two
equations that introduced two questions
they were
so this should be the only solution we
can conclude that exhale change not only
just contains you and and it's exactly
zero me so we're almost down because we
have shown something really nice that if
you take eight I jav it should be any
value and look at this norm it should be
either zero or M cannot take any other
value it were already very close to the
group condition to prove the group
condition let's fix I and be so let's
say I want to improve that the ice row
and the Bistro if you take the harder my
product it's another low in the matrix
let's fix I&B we said jay to be one so
this becomes 0 vector then we have that
this song this is known
the end because it's a discrete unitary
matrix I know all these rows together
form an orthogonal basis I can just use
possible to show that this sum should be
code to exactly n school this is because
these vectors or have all the entries of
roots of unity so all these entries on
roots of unity zar know exactly what
it's known it so here is something
strange like I can I know that each of
these terms here should be either 0 or M
Squared but I also know there is some
transfer so the only chance is that
there is exactly there exists of a
substep this equals m and we're done
because we have two vectors there in the
product as not em on the other hand we
know that all these factors they share
the same first entry but their first
entries are always one remember in the
condition we require that the first row
in the first column are all one so we
have two vectors in the product is M as
no ma'am they share the same forced
entry books are one the only chance you
can satisfy this is that they are
actually the same thing which tell us
steps you take the animal product of
device row in the piece value would get
this which is exactly the group
condition take the heart of our product
of any two vectors row vectors again
another row vector so this finishes the
proof of the group condition and I
thought you can prove that what we
covered today we covered most of their
ways
these type of events and we covered this
segment of proof called the new
condition above where we demonstrated
these techniques of warp engines and
informations and these are widely used
in English earlier sometimes all you
need is to take these techniques to an
extreme for example sometimes you need
not just one layer of interpolation of
multilayers and sometimes you need to
design crazy gruff gadgets such as as
this one so the plan for tomorrow is I
will cover spend most of the time on the
dichotomy for our way to CSP so I will
cover the trap definitive material and
techniques using this type of mean like
not yet polymorphisms and witness
functions and also the main continuous
and then i'll try to see try to
generalize it to know- and complex CSP
in the technical some we have minus one
with a clunker is to write but when Kari
so you can also use on with some
restriction on the gradual function
oh oh I see so so you can yeah yes so I
don't know how that's related it's here
like a the number I mean generally the
number what happen right so you're
saying what if the its minus one but the
polynomial is not over Z to build is the
polynomial armies at laces on but Apollo
mia has like a crossing term has to be
nice also car yeah I think that's sick
can be also soft giving a serum but you
need to clear the connection my past
really like how to catalyze care of you
I think if if if if it's like to teach
you the example of Q something like the
power of two you should be able to do
some generalization there and actually
in our proof the most difficult case is
when q is like a power to hear is oh
it's actually much simpler than the case
when it's a power to and I think that
the reason behind it is exactly what you
say look like when you when you have
coefficients that are even there
interesting thing like more interesting
than going on there compared to you like
the odd case
tourism all the time
it's actually okay